what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch today a fun spider-man
video again this one is tom hollands and
dia and jacob babylon react to their
original cast auditions i've never
personally seen their cast auditions
this will be the first for a lot of
people involved anyhow if you could
leave a like flip that like button you
know what we say when it's spider-man
let's get to it
[Music]
wow i've wanted to see these for so long
[Music]
so we're
obviously shooting spider-man 3 and
we're all going to sit down and watch
our audition tapes
that laughs
[Music]
and walked back in the scene
have you ever played down earth
they are thrashing that limiter
thank you the self-care
that's the best that's the best
[Laughter]
i was just wondering if you're nervous
about the debate is this is supposed to
follow i think sex nicole has a pretty
solid legging yours is just really good
audition
even back then
oh yeah right right he has mono tell me
more
i feel like my whole audition i was like
so nervous that i can say the right
words well
i'd say they made a good decision hey
look
not me right now not us not us look at
us look at us good job guys wow good job
everyone watching that's great
let's do it we should go and make a
movie exactly how we played those scenes
let's do it all right
oh no goodness
i watched that movie
i could barely watch a video i did six
months ago i can't imagine what it's
like to watch this thing when you
auditioned for it years ago
especially
because you have that feeling of like
i've grown so much not only physically
but also like as a performer i think at
that time i'd imagine zendaya coming off
of whatever that disney thing that she
was on probably had the most fame and
was most accustomed to like the
filmmaking and whatnot is probably more
used to seeing herself on camera because
they even joked about like yeah she's
actually just doing like a really good
one this is like today actually this is
good acting yeah but you know especially
for people like tom hall and jacob
battle on to go back and realize like oh
i've grown so much as an actor for so
much as talented to see that you can see
like where all that converting the
cringe into slamming on the table
smacking things around ah that was a
that was a delight i really enjoyed the
hell out of that video yeah absolutely
and it's fun to see the things that
maintained from way back then that still
made like that laugh he does like some
of those mannerisms that made it into
even the later movies are still part of
the performances even though they are
you know a little funny to look back on
now and yeah just to see yeah the way
jacob battle and walks out of frame
comes back in to restart the scene like
things that yeah obviously now you know
you just go into it but it's so much fun
to see yeah like the very origins of
that and the sort of shy beginnings that
led to the biggest movie of all time or
one of the biggest movies of all time
anyway can someone explain to me in the
comments i thought jacob battle on is
bald
and he's wearing a wig i thought he was
even in his audition he was but then
here in this video when he's reacting
he's wearing a wig or is that his actual
hair does he just prefer the shaved look
is it like when christian bale would do
american accents in his interviews when
he was playing an american character to
not confuse the audience i'm playing a
guy with hair yeah did they put on a wig
just to not confuse people because 99
time when he does promos he's he's bald
so i was like whoa where'd all this had
a hair come from is that a wig or is
that real i was a little bit lost there
but anyway yeah i mean looking back at
this footage and seeing just how much
they've all grown i would say that it's
funny like tom hall is obviously perhaps
the biggest star of the mall like
uncharted was a big hit he is spider-man
however i think zendaya is like the most
talented one if you guys have watched
i'm telling you if you have not seen you
before yet hey you should definitely be
of a certain age if you haven't seen
before you it's quite mature content
needless to say but there is
episodes in there where zendaya is just
beyond phenomenal and and such a nuanced
natural actress i can't stress that
enough so i would like oh yeah she's
probably the better performer
or charismatic star and i don't really
know jacob babylon's other work i don't
really know what else he's been in do
you nope just the spider might feel bad
saying that but just the spider-man
movies although i would love to see him
in more things i mean i feel like he
does kind of get the bottom rung of the
totem pole because of the flashy stuff
that tom holland and zendaya are
involved in but he's really great and
he's got great comedic timing so i hope
that yeah this still blossoms outward
for him as much as it does for them you
know i wonder if he still has to
audition though because every actor gets
to a certain stage and there's like
other actors that i know of or i'm still
surprised by oh they make you audition
still like there's certain actors of
certain levels that i've met where you'd
think they they only go off of being
offered roles because auditioning is
just this whole other process in and of
itself into like audition for a marvel
film you got so much competition you got
a lot of people trying to get that role
so to narrow it down to the right person
there's just a lot of pressure on both
ends there's a lot of pressure on that
one person and who's going to play the
role and there's a lot of pressure on
the people picking the role and so many
other variables go into that as well i
think the thing that i really like about
what marvel does is they seem to mainly
go off of the best performer for the job
more than anything else like i
i'm fortunate enough to know like enough
you know
producer director people where i won't
name drop anyone but i know enough to
the point where i can get these stories
of you you sit in all these auditions
and you hear like the craziest stuff
i've heard this before like that
person's the best actor but that other
one has a bigger social media following
maybe we should go with her these are
like things they actually discuss in the
casting process in the audition room and
it's so cool to see that
the three of them relatively unknown or
moderately known
easily three not not like super famous
people to be able to get a chance at
this movie and to see just how popular
they've got it it's really is a story of
overcoming odds there's so many odds
factored against you we're so used to
seeing people where they're already
famous we're already like hey overnight
star something like that but when you
see this it just reminds you of the hard
work labor the focus commitment all that
factored in and on top of all that you
have to beat unsurmountable odds and
they did it so this is really inspiring
to for them to go back and see that it's
like they might be laughing and cringing
but it's really inspiring really yeah
absolutely and too i mean i've heard a
lot of actors talk different ways about
the self tape versus being in the room
and just looking at these here it almost
feels like yeah with that self tape
they're able to especially tom holland
bring out that creativity that i imagine
bridges the gap that much more into the
charm that will lead to a casting choice
like that that whole thing with the
boots where he does the the web gag or
he flips into frame he won't be able to
do that in the room with the producers
and stuff like that and so yeah it also
gets to show the creativity that can
sometimes be that extra ounce of
lightning in the bottle that gets you a
roll like this you know so it's it's
it's a fascinating look at the approach
and and then you know i'm not like an
actor actor but you know thinking to me
i'm like damn it seems like almost self
tape would be the way to go because then
you can
be creative and put your stamp on
something without getting alienated in
the room because oftentimes in a person
to person environment that's actually
discouraged so yeah it's a good sort of
glimpse into
you know what leads to these
massive blockbusters as well as any
other indie movie
true that all right guys well uh
spiderman no way home did you pre-order
it leave your thoughts down below
thanks for being here with us to have a
good laugh uh while funny also inspiring
in a lot of ways uh hey let's end this
with the paper
oliver hey hamlet
h-a-m-e-l-i-n guys new patron you know
the journal oh
standing for auto octavius hey that
works hey l standing for
level up because i
think you are at the highest level i for
igniting my soul v for vendetta
okay e for equality because that's what
oliver believes in an r for a real one
because you're the realest of them all
oliver oliver thank you so much for
being part of our patreon page you're a
sexy sob hopefully you enjoy the limited
content we put up over there very minor
see ya